[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا انها الساعه ستون
برنامج اخباري خاص ومتنوع وبقاع سريع
ومختلفا جدا نحلل الاحداث بابعادها وبعمق
وبين العاجل والمهم نضع امامكم الاهم
والصوره الكامله البدايه من العناوين
زلزالنا يهدد الاقتصاد الايراني النظام
يتنصل والبرلمان يفضحه والحل ربما في
افكار الروسيه
حضروا تيك توك لاعتبارات الامن القومي
والخصوصيه وهناك استثناءات
وفي ملفات الساعه ستون اين نشا كورونا بين
مختان الصيني وفورده
ثلاث سنوات ولا اجابات
هجره عكسيه فرضت عليهم الماسي تلاحق
اللاجئين السوريين من عرائط تركيا الى
عرائس
[موسيقى]
محادثه نوويه في طهران الى ماذا تحدث هل
هي لتحريك جهود مفاوضات العوده للاتفاق
النووي ام هي لزياده عمليات التفتيش قبل
بلوغ طيران عتبه القنبله النوويه هنا يجيب
المدير العام للوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه بدعوه ايران الى الشفافيه بشان
برنامجها النووي وفي زيارته اليها كان امن
مستقبليه رفع العقوبات الدوليه القاسيه
ولو جزئيا لانعاش الاقتصاد المنحك وكبح
السقوط الحر للعمله المسحوق بالتضخم اما
في الشارع فالبعض ارجع انهيار الاقتصاد
للعقوبات الامريكيه فيما يرى اخرون ان ذلك
يعود الى سوء الاداره وان اختلف
الايرانيون حول اسباب التدهور الاقتصادي
فان سوء الحال يجمعهم اذا السقوط حر
للعمله الوطنيه في ايران حجج جاهزه يقدمها
نظام وغضب شعبي تصاعد خاصه من اولئك الذين
يكافحون لتامين قوتهم اليومي نصف سكان
ايران يعيشون تحت خط الفقر وبحسب موقع
مودرنسي الاسباب تعود الى ارتفاع الاسعار
وتراجع القيمه الشرائيه للعمله المحليه
غضب اجبر المرشد علي خميمائي على الاعتراف
بوجود ثغرات اقتصاديه عديده خمن ان تحدث
عن ثنائيه التضخم وانخفاض قيمه العمله
الوطنيه نسبه ارتفاع الاسعار بلغت في بعض
المدن
53% والحديث هنا لمصادر مح
[موسيقى]
ليه
في خضمي ما تعيشه ايران من هزات ارضيه
اجتماعيه وحتى سياسيه لا تقتصر على
علاقاتها مع الخارج يمكن القول ان الارض
تهتز فعليا بفعل زلزال اقتصادي ارتداداته
تزداد عنفا يوما بعد اخر فقدت العمله
الايرانيه نحو 50% من قيمتها تقريبا منذ
اندلاع الاحتجاجات في سبتمبر الماضي
الدولار وصل لمستوى قياسي امام تومان اكثر
من 57 الفا لكن ما السبب هناك ميلاد امن
للتبرير الاحتجاجات والعدو عدو ايران لجا
الى خلق التضخم في سوق العملات لاستهداف
المواطنين واستهداف حياتهم ومعيشتهم
حتى نوفمبر 2022 لم يرتفع سعر الدولار
باكثر من 2000 توما اي اننا استلمنا وكان
سعره
27,600 توما اي عندما بدات حكومتنا كانت
اقل من 30 الف تومان لذا هذه القفزه
بحوالي 20,000 و30000 مشكوك فيها من اين
اتت لا اريد ان اقول انها ايدي الاجانب
فقط
عمليا يلمس الناس ذلك بشكل واضح في
الاسواق كل شيء ارتفع سعره وتحولت ابسط
الاشياء لاحلام وهكذا يروي الايرانيون
الامهم لكن المفارقه ان هذا التدني الحاد
في قيمه الريال الايرانيه بعد شهر او اكثر
بقليل على تعهد رئيس بحد ذاته بمواجهه
الوضع الاقتصادي والمالي المتدهور
اتمنى بعون الله وحسب هذه المؤشرات التي
قدمتها وكلها تشير الى النمو تاكدوا من ان
سعر العمله والذهب والعديد من الغلاء في
البلد ثقوا بانه سينخفض باذن الله
غير ان هذه الاسابيع جاءت بما لا تشتهيه
حكومه الرئيس يقرر البنك المركزي الايراني
ضخه 700 مليون دولار في سوق النقد الاجنبي
للحد من تدهور الريال امام العملات
الرئيسيه خطاباته رئيسيه لم تقنع
المواطنين الذين لجاوا الى الدولارات
والعملات الصعبه الاخرى او الذهب لحفظ
مدخراتهم كلمات رئيسي لم تقنع المواطنين
وحتى الصحافه بل اعضاء في البرلمان الذين
عبروا عن ذلك بطريقتهم
بحاج رئيسي اخبرتك حضوريا في البرلمان عن
عدم وجود تنسيق بين فريقك الاقتصادي لكن
لم يحدث شيئا يا سيد رئيسي فريقك
الاقتصادي بلا خطه وضعيف خذ الامر على
محمل الجد الى متى سيتعين على الناس دفع
ثمن سوء الاداره وعدم كفاءه المسؤولين
انهيار العمله الايرانيه يثير المخاوف من
تبعات كبيره في كافه القطاعات في البلاد
قلقا يتعمق مع احكام التيار المتطرف في
ايران على السياسه الخارجيه لكن ما دور
هذا التيار في الوضع الاقتصادي والملك
ابحث عن الاتفاق النووي والعقوبات هذا
التيار الموازي يعرقل التوصل الى اتفاق مع
الغرب وبالتالي تشديد العقوبات ضغوطات
خارجيه بفعل العقوبات كالحد من الصادرات
النفطيه والوصول الى العملات الاجنبيه
واضطرابات داخليه بسبب الاحتجاجات ثنائي
تزعج النظام الايراني وتقلقه في ظل عمله
واقتصاد يحتضرانه
المساله المحدده لقيمه العمله الوطنيه
والعملات وكذلك السياسات والاجراءات التي
اتخذها البنك المركزي لجمهوريه ايران
الاسلاميه حتى الذكرى السنويه الاولى
للحكومه او حتى نهايه سبتمبر اي الى
التاريخ الذي لم تبدا الاضطرابات
والاحتجاجات واعمال الشغب في بلادنا نجح
البنك المركزي في وضع سياساته سواء من حيث
التحويلات او من حيث السوق المشكل وهو سوق
العملات
ركود يضرب الاسواق في العاصمه الايرانيه
تقول تقارير لوسائل اعلام محليه والاسباب
ليست بعيده العراق ساحه ماليه واقتصاديه
طالما استغلتها ايران لمصالحها امتثال
بغداد لمعايير نظام التحويلات الدولي
سويفت يصاعد من التفات طيران على العقوبات
الامريكيه لكن تلتف طهران على العقوبات
الغربيه وتحاول ايجاد البديل دوما في
القطاع المالي او النفطي وغيرهما البحث عن
بديل لنظام سويفت المالي العالمي بعد فصل
ايران عن شبكه سويفت وهو ما واجهه روسيا
ايضا بات هذا الامر نقطه التقاء مشتركه
بين البلدين ماليا ومصرفيا ولدا على
العقوبات الغربيه ربطت موسكو وطهران
انظمتها المصرفيه سعيا منهما للالتفاء
للالتفاف على الرقابه
الامريكيه والافلات منها بالمبادلات
الماليه وح دولار من التبادل التجاري فيما
بينهما ماذا يعني ذلك يعني ان المصارف
الايرانيه ستتمكن من التواصل المباشر مع
البنوك الروسيه والاتصال مع اكثر من مئه
مصرف اجنبي غير روسيه في اربعه عشره دوله
وفي سبتمبر الماضي دشنا العمل ببطاقه مير
المصرفيه الروسيه في ايران كخطوه تمهيديه
انذاك لدمج نظام الدفع المصرفيين مير
الروسيه واجتاب الايراني هذا ماليا غير ان
طيران لم تكتفي بذلك فقطاع النفط الايراني
له طرقه للوصول الى الاسواق الكبرى
وتحديدا الى الصين اكبر مستهلك للطاقه ثمه
زياده ملحوظه في صادرات النفط الايرانيه
والحديث هنا عن ارتفاع خلال اشهر بمتوسط
حوالي مليون برميل النفط يوميا كيف
رحلته شحنات النفط الايرانيات تصل الى
الصين عبر حلقات وصل وهي عده دول ومن
بينها ماليزيا قبل ان تستقر في الصين تشير
بيانات اداره معلومات الطاقه الامريكيه
وشركه كابتلر عام 2021 الى ان حجم صادرات
ايران النفطيه الى ماليزيا مثلا بلغت سته
واربعين في المئه وثمانيه وعشرين في المئه
للصين و7% لدول اخرى
اذا منطاد في السماء واخر في الهاتف
الاخطار الصينيه تداهم امريكا او هكذا تظن
وليست وحدها في الساعه بعد دقيقه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد على ضوء ما تتعرض له
النساء في ايران طالبه ايرانيه ترتدي قبل
دخولها الى المدرسه حقيبه على شكل قناع
يقي من الغاز رسمه كاريكاتريه للفنان
الايراني ميلاد وسوقي لكن ما القصه ميلاده
وثقي اراد ايصال رساله للعالم تتعلق
بهجمات الغاز السام التي استهدفت الطالبات
ايرانيات في مناطق مختلفه من البلاد
هذه القائمه الطويله الخوف يتسلل الى
بريطانيا لكن التعاطي مع الخطر يحتمل
تاجيل لاغراض انتخابيه
قد يكون الهوس بمنصه تيك توك قد وصل حد
الجنون بين افراد الجيل الجديد في
بريطانيا حيث يتجاوز عدد مستخدميه اكثر من
عشره ملايين لكنه بات هما ومصدر قلق لا
ينتهي للحكومات الغربيه ومنها بريطانيا
التي احتارت كيف تتعامل مع تطبيق الصيني
فبعد فرض قيود على استخدام التطبيق بين
السياسيين والموظفين الحكوميين في كل من
الولايات المتحده واوروبا لاسباب تتعلق
بالامن السيبراني لم تحدد بريطانيا موقفها
من التطبيقات هي اعتبرت ان قرار استخدام
التطبيق يعود لحريه اختيار النواب
والوزراء الذين لا يزال عدد كبير منهم
يستخدم التطبيق لجذب الناخبين الصغار قبيل
الانتخابات المجمعه نهايه العام المقبل
الاعتراض على تيك توك يعود الى القلق من
تجسس الاستخبارات الصينيه على المسؤولين
الغربيين من خلال التطبيق لكن الصين تحاول
اقناع بريطانيا بعدم السير على خطى اوروبا
والولايات المتحده اذ من المخطط ان يقدم
المستشار العام لتيك توك ايجازا الاسبوع
المقبل في وسمينستر لشرح مدى سلامه
استخدام التطبيق فهل ستقتنع بريطانيا
اذا تيك توك يتجه الى ان يكون ممنوعا من
التسلل اكثر لكن هي حقيقه ان وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي كلها متهمه بانتهاك
الخصوصيه والمتاجره بالبيانات وكثيرا ما
تعرضت لدفع غرامات كتلك التي دفعتها ميثا
وجوجل للاتحاد الاوروبي فلماذا الحظر لتيك
توك بالذات اولا التطبيق اعترف نهايه
العام الماضي اجرت بيض دانس تحقيقا حول
مراقبه صحفيين مجله فوربز والالتقاء
التجسس عليهم وذلك على اثر التحقيق طرد
كريس
المراجعين الداخليين في بايدنز الذي قاد
عمليه التجسس واستقاله ايضا المدير
التنفيذي للشركه سونغي الذي قدمت اليه
تفاصيل العمليه الاعتراف كان بمراسلات
رسميه لتيك توك مع المجله حاله فرديه ربما
غير ان خلفها هناك ما اججج قلق الحكومات
الغربيه من التطبيق ومن خلفه الاستخبارات
الصينيه وما يعزز المخاوف وجود قانون صيني
دخل حيز التنفيذ في 2016 قانون تحت مسمى
مكافحه الارهاب يفرض على شركات الانترنت
العامله في الصين تسليم مفاتيح التشفير
وكلمات المرور للحكومه الصينيه عند الطلب
الحق القانون باخر دخل حيز التنفيذ في
2017 يتيح الرقابه لصيق على بيانات
المستخدمين وتخزينها في الشركات العامله
في الصين بناء عليه تحذر تقارير امنيه
امريكيه بالنف الصين نظريا يمكنها استخدام
البيانات للتجسس على المستخدمين الافراد
ومراقبه انشطتهم ومواقعهم من خلال الاي بي
ادرس عمليا هذا ما حدث في اكتوبر الماضي
مع صحفي المجله مج له فوربس ويتصاعد الخوف
على سلم الخطر الامريكي الى حد استخدام
الصين لكل المعلومات لديها في مهاجمه
الولايات المتحده بحملات توزعزع استقرار
البلاد ولهذا جاء حظر التطبيق على اجهزه
موظفي الادارات الحكوميه خلال مده اقصاها
30 يوما لكن هناك استثناءات
امر البيت الابيض الوكالات الفيدراليه بان
تحضر في غضون 30 يوما تطبيق تيك توك على
هواتفها واجهزتها بسبب مخاطره على الامن
القوميه الامريكي الا ان مذكره صادره عن
مكتب الاداره والميزانيه في البيت الابيض
تعطي استثناءات محدوده قد تصل مدتها الى
عام واحد لوكالات انشطه انفاذ القانون
ومصالح وانشطه الامن القوميه والبحوث
الامنيه لكن على هذه الوكالات ان تقتصر
باستعمال الاستثناءات على الحالات التي
يكون فيها استخدام تيك توك امرا بالغ
الاهميه لمهمتها وعندما تكون الطرق
البديله غير قابله للتطبيق كما يسمح
للوكالات الامنيه باستخدامه للتحقيق وتمنح
الاستثناءات من قبل رئيس الوكاله او من
ينوب عنه بعدما يقرر بان الاستخدام ستكون
له علاقه واضحه بمصالح او انشطه الامن
القوميه
لكن بغض النظر عن هذه الاستثناءات فالحظر
يطال اجهزه الادارات الفيدراليه
الخارجيه والبيت الابيض بالطبع عدد
العاملين فيها ضمن 40 وحده تقنيه واداريه
يبلغ حوالي سته الاف موظف لكن ازمه التيك
توك ليست بالعدد وان تضاعف عشر مرات بل
بما هو اتا خلال الشهر الجاري مع تصويت
مجلس النواب على مشروع قانون يمنح الرئيس
جو بايدن سلطه حظر التيك توك بشكل كامل من
الولايات المتحده هذه الضربه القاسمه هناك
اكثر من 138 مليون مستخدم امريكي نشط
للتطبيق الذي تصير واشنطن على انه خطر ولم
تمنع كل التحذيرات الامريكيين من تنزيله
210 ملايين مره حتى نهايه العام الماضي
ماذا يعني ذلك يعني ان التيك توك يمتلق
قاعده بيانات
من سكان الولايات المتحده ونصف هؤلاء من
البالغين ومن وجهه نظر او بالاحرى اتهامات
صناع القرار السياسي والامني الامريكيين
فان هذه البيانات ليست فقط في متناول يد
الحكومه الصينيه بل استخدامها في الكونجرس
مايكل ماكول شبهت تيك توك باحدث الاخبار
اخطار الصينيه على الساحه الامريكيه واقصد
في سماء الولايات المتحده من طاب التجسس
المنطاد في الهواتف يؤرق كذلك القاره
العجوز والضربه للتيك توك ستكون مزدوجه لو
قرر الاتحاد الاوروبي السيره على السكه
الامريكيه
125 مليون اوروبي يسجلون دخولهم شهريا الى
التطبيق معركه الخصوصيه هي جزء من كل انها
حرب الكترونيه وشرسه جوانبها تجاريه
وربحيه والشعبيه لتيك توك مقلقه بدرجه
كبيره
الامريكيون في الصداره صداره الاستخدام
يليهم الاندونيسيون بتسعه وتسعين مليون
مستخدم ثلاثه وسبعون مليون وخمسمائه الف
من البرازيل و51 من روسيا المجموعه يتجاوز
مليار مستخدم مشهد شهريا وهذه هي القواعد
الجماهيريه لا تملكها سوى التطبيقات
الامريكيه اذا العمليا تيك توك ويتشات
المصنفان على وتشات المصنف ايضا على انه
الخطر الصيني الثاني والمصمم من قبل شركه
باي دانس ايضا باتاه المنافسين الابرز
لانستغرام فيسبوك يوتيوب وواتساب
اذا للمزيد ينضم الينا من بروكسيل انريكي
سربيتو المتخصص في الشؤون الاوروبيه
والشرق الاوسط اهلا بك اذا ما اخطر ما في
تطبيق تيك توك على الحكومات الغربيه الامن
القومي الخصوصيه ام المنافسه الالكترونيه
كما شرحنا قبل قليل
من هذه النقاط التي ورد ذكرها من وجهه
النظر اعتقد ان هذا القرار الذي صدر على
المفوضيه الاوروبيه والاداره الامريكيه
بحظر التطبيق قد يكونوا جزءا لا يتجزا من
اللغه الموجهه الى الصين هي رساله مفادها
باننا لا نثق بكم ولا نعلم ما الذي قد
يحدث فيما بعد لان التيك توك او اي او اي
من
المنصات الاخرى لا نعلم تماما ما الذي
يمكن ان يتم بتلك البيانات التي يتم جمعها
من خلال هواتفنا المتحركه في حقيقه الامر
جوجل على سبيل المثال يعرف الكثير عن
حياتنا اليوميه
وهذا امر حقيقي تيك توك بالمقابل
واستخداماته قد تكون لارسال رسائل الى
الصين مفادها باننا لا نثق بكم
وما زلنا نقف في المعسكر
المضاد في اشياء كثيره
من وجهه نظري المستخدمين فان جلهم
يستخدمون تيك توك لاظهار حياتهم
بصوره شخصيه وما من شيء خاف على الجميع
لكن بكل تاكيد يمكن
استخدامه من قبل الصين وهذا احتمال اقول
انه احتمال وافترض ان هذا هو واقع الحال
بالنسبه للصين لكن في النهايه السؤال
المطروح لهذه التحركات قد تكون ذات طبيعه
دبلوماسيه موجهه الى الصين سنترك وجهه نظر
الحكومه جانبا وانها قالت ان القيود على
تيك توك تعد مضلله ولكن بيضه تقول انه لم
يتم التجاوب من الجانب الاوروبي مع
الضمانات التي يمكن ان تقدمها هي استثمرت
بالفعل 600 مليون يورو على ثلاثه مراكز
لتخزين البيانات وهذا في اطار ضمانات قدمت
شيئا مشابها ايضا للولايات المتحده على
هذا يعني من هذا القبيل بمراكز في
سنغافوره وايضا في فرجينيا الا تعد هذه
الضمانات حقيقيه
اعتقد انه من الصعب ان نثق باي طرف
على
الجانب الاخر من هذه التكنولوجيا الغامضه
هذا التطبيق قد كان له تداعيات هنا حاله
حال التكنولوجيا الجيل الخامس جي 5 فاذا
كان الدول كثيره ترغب كانت ترغب بان تكون
في مكانه الطليعه بحصولها على هذه
التكنولوجيا لكنها اكتشفت ان البنيه
التحتيه معظمه قد تم تصنيعها في الصين
ولدها
ابتعدت عن هذا الامر وبدات تواجه بعض
المشاكل الامنيه
هذا
بالنهايه مساله ثقه
ومساله الثقه هذه تتمثل باين يمكننا ان
نثق الصين وفي اي موضع تصعب الاجابه على
هذا السؤال اعتقد انه قد تكون هناك بعض
الاحتمالات لاستخدام المعلومات من قبل
الصين لكن بكل تاكيد انهم بعيدون كل البعد
عننا
والنقطه التي تثير الاهتمام في حياته
الناس العاديين لا اعلم اذا ما كانت هناك
نتيجه حتميه فمثلا الصينيون يستخدمون هذه
التكنولوجيا من اجل السيطره على
مواطنيهم وهذا صحيح فانا كنت في الصين
واعلم
الحديث الذي يدور مثلا عن عن الحمض النووي
لاي شخص يتوجه لعياده الطبيب اي انهم
يستخدمون التكنولوجيا من اجل السيطره على
حياه الشعوب في الصين اذا كان بمقدورهم
فعل ذلك في الصين فلماذا لا يفعلونه في
اماكن اخرى
ومنذ متى كان بمقدورنا ان نثق
وان نحترم خصوصيه المستخدمين لا اعلم هذا
الامر
لكن بالنسبه للسمات الخاصه بهذا التطبيق
فاعتقده بانه
كافه ملامح ومعلومات الاشخاص العاديين قد
تكونوا مكشوفه نعم اشكرك جزيل الشكر
المتخصص في الشؤون الاوروبيه والشرق
الاوسط
في امريكا غابت تنسيق فزاد الغموض حول
مشاي كورونا في الساعه بعد دقيقه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد فيروس كورونا حتى وان
هدات وتيره انتشاره ومتحوراته فهو من حين
لاخر يعود للواجهه لكن يبقى السؤال الذي
لم يتم الاجابه عليه منذ ثلاث سنوات كيف
تسربت
اختلفت الدول والمؤسسات حول مصادر الجائحه
بين نظريه التسريب غير المتعمد والمصدر
الحيواني نظريه التسرب يدعمها وجود اكثر
من حاله انتشار تسرب للفيروسات من معامل
بحثيه عالميا وخاصه في الصين اسعار احد
افراد عائله فيروسات كورونا تسرب مرتين في
عام 2003 مرت في سنغافوره ومره في تايوان
قبل ان يتسرب الفيروس مرتين ايضا من مختبر
في بكين عام 2004 وبالتالي من البديهي ان
تعتمد نظريات التسريب على مختبر مهان
فيروسات كورونا هي صلب ابحاثه وهنا يبرز
اسم شيء جينلي مديره المركز مركز الامراض
المعديه وفي معهد ووهان وهي المعروفه باسم
المراه الخفاش اسمها جاء لسبب فعلى مدار
18 عاما جمع فريقها اكثر من 20 الف عينه
من مستعمر الخفافيش ارقام اندفعت علماء
لترجيح نظريه اخرى وهي ان يكون كوفيد 19
قد وصل الى ووهان عبر اصابه احد اعضاء
فريقها خلال عمليه جمع عينات من الخفافيش
لكن ابحاث المعهد تضمنت دراسات لفيروسات
من عائله الفيروس التاجي ومن بينها فيروس
ار اي تي جي 13 الذي وجدته الصحه العالميه
عند تفتيشها للمعهد ويتطابق في
96% من حمضه النووي مع كوفيد 19 نسبه قد
تبدو كبيره لكن في علم الجناب هي لا شيء
تكاد تكون نفس النسبه المشتركه فالحمض
النووي للانسان والقرد والامر معقد اذا
علميا ما قد يفسر تناقض نتائج تحقيقات
المؤسسات الامريكيه
تاكد مدير الاف بي اي مره اخرى ان فيروس
كورونا خرج من مختبر في الصين المهم في
هذا التقدير الصادر عن هذا المبنى في
واشنطن انه متوسط الثقه اي ان لديه
اثباتات افضل من التي في حوزه وزاره
الطاقه الامريكيه وتقديرها هو منخفض الثقه
ولكن المهم ايضا هو ان هناك وكالتين من
اصل تسعه تقول في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ان السبب هو خروج الفيروس من
مختبر فيما تقول الوكالات الاخرى انه بسبب
حادث في احد اسواقي وهون السبب في هذه
الاختلافات يعود الى ان كل وكاله تعمل
لوحدها والصين لا تتعاون
بالعوده الى المصدر المزعوم مختبرهان احدى
علمائه لمنجيان فاجات العالم في سبتمبر
2020 زعمه ان بكين صنعت الفيروس ونشرت
عمدا ليقوم تويتر بتعليق حسابها بتهمه نشر
الشائعات دون دلائل العلميه بعدها بشهرين
في نوفمبر 2020 ذكرت صحيفه نيويورك
والملياردير الصينيه
رتب لسفرها الى الولايات المتحده ودربوها
على الظهور في وسائل الاعلام اليمينيه
البعض اكد صحه ما قالت الجديده وبعد
انتشار الصور للعالمه الصينيه مع كل من
بان ورودوي
[موسيقى]
اذا
ظهر الفيروس في وهران منطقيا اذا الصين هي
المنشا لكن اين في الصين وهنا تنقسم
الروايات والفرضيات فهل خرج من سوقه ونان
للماكولات البحريه بانتقاله من الحيوان
الى الانسان ام من مختبر ووهان والفرضيه
التي تعترض بكين بشده عليها لانه يحملها
مسؤوليه الجائحه ويسيس القضيه على حد
وصفها الصين تقبلت بعد ضغوط دوليه دفعت
بها الولايات المتحده زياره فريق منظمه
الصحه العالميه لها في يناير 2021 لكنها
رفضت تكرار التجربه واجراء تحقيق جديد
طلبته المنظمه خاصه بعد ترجيحها فرضيه
المختبر عاكست هنا بكين المؤامره سعت لوضع
واشنطن تحت طائله الاتهام والملاحقه ضخت
زخما كبيرا في حمله دعائيه لتكون قاعده
العسكريه في ولايه ميريلاند تحت المجهر
غير انها لم تنجح لكن هناك ما يدعم
فرضيتها القاعده المنشاه منذ ثلاثينات
القرن الماضي تحوي مختبرا بيولوجيا هاما
وهنا نحن في يوليو 2019 اغلقت القاعده
الامريكيه والمختبر ابوابه بشكل مفاجئ
والسبب انتشار التهاب رئوي بين عامليه
ومنه الى ولايه مختلفه شبهت خطوره اعراضه
لايبولا الفيروس الاخضر قبل ظهور الاخطر
الفيروس الصيني كما روج له الرئيس السابق
دونالد ترامب ظهر في بلاده في ديسمبر 2019
وهذا كشف لمعاهد الصحه الوطنيه الامريكيه
اي في نفس الوقت الذي اعلنت الصين عن
اكتشافه
الصين دافعت عن بعض اتهاماتي واشنطن
بانتاج الفيروس عمدا في وهان واتاهمت
واشنطن نفسها بالوقوف وراء تسريب الفيروس
بكين تشير الى تقرير نيويورك تايم في
اغسطس 2019 اغلاق مؤقت لمعهد البحوث
الطبيه للامراض المعديه التابعه للجيش
الامريكي في بورتاتريك خوفا من تسرب مياه
مستخدمه في الابحاث الى المواطنين وبان
المياه قد تتضمن مواد سامه تمثل تمثيل
خطير للجمهور او صحه الحيوان والنبات او
المنتجات الحيوانيه وايضا النباتيه بكين
اشارت لتاريخ واشنطن في الحروب البيولوجيه
بدءا من عام
1945 بعد هزيمه اليابان منحت واشنطن
الحصانه السياسيه للعسكريين اليابانيين في
الوحده 731 وحده سريه للحرب الجرثوميه في
المق حصلت واشنطن على الالاف من نتائج
الاختبارات الدقيقه للاسلحه البيولوجيه
والكيميائيه اجريت على سكان الصين خزنت
منشاه فورد داترك العسكريه في ولايه
ميرلاند التجارب اليابانيه التي تقول
الصين ان واشنطن استمرت بها لتطوير
اسلحتها البيولوجيه تضمنت تشريح الاسرى
الاحياء بتر اطرافهم لدراسه تاثير فقدان
الدم على الجسم وبعد الحرب العالميه
الثانيه امنت وكاله الاستخبارات المركزيه
بان السوبيات نجحوا في تطوير عقار او
تقنيه تمكنهم من التحكم في عقول البشر
لتطلق واشنطن برنامج ام كي الترا للتحكم
بالعقل البشري ولادخان التحكم بالعقل
اجريت اختبارات متطرفه على المعتقلين سواء
داخل امريكا او خارج امريكا شملت
الاستخدام الاجباري للعقد قير المهلوسه
والصعق بالكهرباء والاعتداءات الجسديه
[موسيقى]
الزلزال دمار وماساه وما يليه من ايام هي
تحدي الحياه الجديده ونتحدث هنا عن
مليونير تركي نزحوا الى الشمال بحثا عن
ملجا او على الاقل الابتعاد عن المناطق
التي ضربتها الزلازل نزوح الملايين نحو
الشمال رافقه نزوح سوري في الاتجاه
المعاكس رغم ان العثور على خيمه او غطاء
قد يصبح حلما في سوريا الا انهم اختاروا
العوده بعد ان بات اللجوء عاجزا عن
احتوائهم تحالف الحرب والسياسه والطبيعه
اجبرهم على بناء حياتهم للمره الثالثه
معبر باب الهوى تحول الى شاهد على عوده
السوريين قبل سنوات غادر السوريون طلبا
للامان اشهر اللجوء تحولت الى سنوات
وتركيا تحولت الى وطن ثاني شيدوا فيه
بيوتهم واسسوا تجاره او امتحنوا الحرف لكن
اندماجهم لم ي الكثير ومع اقتراب
الانتخابات تحول السوريون الى ورقه سياسيه
انقر هذه المره اعلنت نيتها باعادتهم قبل
ان يرفع الزلزال مشاعر معاداه السوريين
تركيا للاتراك شعار تبناه تبنته المؤسسات
التركيه كما المواطنين البسطاء السوريون
تم توجيههم في خيام تابعه لمنظمه افاد عكس
الاتراك الذين خصصت لهم بيوت مؤقته
السوريون وصفوا الخيام بقدرهم المحتوم ولا
فائده من الهروب من العراء الى العراء
وبالتالي مناخ سوريا سيكون ارحم قليلا الا
ان البرد ايضا يقتل هناك وجاء دور الاوبئه
لتفتك بالسوريين غياب البنيه التحتيه ادى
لانتشار الكوليرا بينما سجل مركز ايواء
المنكوبين في حلب وحدها مئه الف حاله تسمم
غذائي
متعودين نشتغل نترزق الله وقال
حمامات ولا ميت قطعت وكهرباء
الشعب التركي دائما في شعب عنصري الشعب
العنصري يعني دائما موجود بكل شعب بكل
مجتمع في شعب عنصري اما من ضمن المناطق
الزلزال احنا ضمن المناطق انطاكيا كهرمان
مرعش الماضي فيها شوي الشعب التركي صار
انه
عنصريه للشعب السوري وخص مرعيش
والله يحمي هالشعب وهالبلد ويرجعنا لبلدنا
ظلم ظلم
ظلم ظلم ظلمنا في سوريا وانظلمنا
معاناه خمسه ملايين ونصف المليون شخص
شردهم الزلزال في الشمال السوري يتقاسم
مرورها من هجره الصراع الى ما خلف الحدود
الجنوب التركي المنكوب للمقاطعاته 11 هنا
مليون و700 الف لاجئ من اصلي ثلاثه ملايين
يعيشون في تركيا غازي عنتاب مركز الزلزال
الاول تحتضن 460 الف لاجئ هاتاي
430,000 غرفه 330,000
200,000 لاجئ وبالمناسبه عدد السوريين
فيها اكبر من عدد السكان المحليين ويساويه
رسميا واحد من كل شخصين في المقاطعات سوري
وذلك بحسب مفوضيه الامم المتحده لشؤون
اللاجئين الى من يلجا هؤلاء في بلد اللجوء
بعضهم انضم الى اربعين الف متضرر احتوتهم
ملاجئ ومراكز ايواء وبعضهم وجد في العوده
الى الديار كما ذكرنا وان كانت مسحوقه
ملادا او ربما لم يمتلكون الخيار عائلات
في انطاكيا توجهت الى ادلب اللهم يحصلون
على بعض المساعدات من المنظمات المحليه
والجنوب التركي لم يعد ارضا امام الاقتصاد
التركي يعاني اكثر الاتراك بانفسهم يرون
انهم الاولويه والمساعدات لا تكفي الجميع
مشاعر معاداه السوريين ليست وليده الزلزال
فكلما ضاق العيش اتهما السوريون والتهمه
هذه المره نحو البيوت والمحلات والنتيجه
اكثر من اربعين الف سوري غادروا البلاد
عدد مرشح للزياده خاصه وان انقره منحت
رخصه استثنائيه تسمح بمغادره طالبي اللجوء
وعودتهم
صعب اتخذه السوريون قبل سنوات وهم يغادرون
بلادهم اللاجئين اما اليوم فطريق العوده
القصريه لم تكن ايضا مفروشه بالورود
غالبيه العائدين استقرون في المناطق التي
تسيطر عليها المعارضه غياب سلطه موحده جعل
جهات عديده تتقاسم السيطره على هذه
المناطق عوده المعارك لن يكون مفاجاه عكس
تركيا الخيام في شمال سوريا تعتبر الملجا
الوحيد وبسبب ارتفاع الطلب تحولت خيمه
قماشيه الى حلم اسعارها قفزت من 120
دولارا الى 300 دولار الحصول على خيمه
داخل مخيم اللسان نهايه المعاناه
فالكوليرا وجدت في غياب البنيه التحتيه
وتلوث المياه مناخا مناسبا للانتشار
والاصابات قدرت بالمئات
ماساه اللاجئين اعادت الى الاذهان فاجعه
الزلزال التي جمعت السوريين والاتراك
ساترككم ختاما مع العرض التالي محاكاه من
البدايه لكن للاسف ليس للنهايه ماساه
الزلزال مستمره ولن تنتهي من الان وحتى
الساعه المقبله انا حنين الشولي وهذه
الساعه 60
[موسيقى]
احدى ليالي الشتاء الطويل
ابردها السادس من فبراير درجه الحراره صفر
بالضبط
تحت سقف البيت الدافئ احلام بغد يشبه
الامس
لم يكن افضل
انها الرابعه
وسبعه عشره دقيقه
هل هذا حلم ايضا
ليس دوارا
انها هزه مستمره
لا تتوقف
حتما ستيقظ الجميع
دقيقه واربع ثوان
كسرت كل شيء الزمن
الاحلام والمستقبل
اخذت الامينينا من النوم الى الموت في
مخاض الانقاض قبل انتشال ثلاثه واربعين
الفا وخمسمائه منهم جثثا هامتا
هي دقيقه زلزال ضخم بقوه
7.8 درجات على مقياس ريختر وهنا في غازي
عنتاب في نورداك حجم الكارثه لا يصدق
اختفت ملامح الحي وكان الزلزال وقع على
سطح الارض صحيح نسبيا عمقه كان 18 كيلو
متر وهذه البقعه حيث اقف ليست المركز او
البؤره
الكارثه وقعت في بازرجيك شمالي المحافظه
في كهرمان مرعش المنكوبه وسنعلم لاحقا ان
نكبتها ستحل على عشر مقاطعات اخرى امتدا
اثر الزلزال اليها ليدمر اكثر من 105 الاف
مبنى على 500 كم
زلزال ثاني لا ليس بعد هذه هزه ارتداديه
بقوه
6.4 درجات ستاتي على المزيد من المباني
والارواح وسيليها اكثر
سبعه الاف
ومئتي هزه
لكن الزلزال الاول كان بقوه 500
[موسيقى]
انها الواحده واربع وثلاثون دقيقه ظهرا
لا صوت يعلو الان على صوت جرافات تزيح
انقاد وركام بيوت ابتلعت سكانها واخرى
تهدم ما تبقى من خرسانه عرضتها ثنائيه
الزلزلين والفساد مصيرها الانهيار عاجلا
ام اجلا 50 الف مبنى واكثر من هذا المكان
والزمان بات الوقت يقاس بخساره الارواح
سباق مع الموت لكبح العداد المفجع للوفيات
المؤكده واخر مع الصقيع وتدني الحراره
ليلا الى 15 درجه تحت الصفر تحديدا في
البستان
وللمفقودين عداد اخر لا يوثقه سوى الناجنه
وشهاداتهم بمن ترك خلفهم دون حظ او رائحه
هكذا سجلت لحظات الموت وقليل من البطوله
عليه فرق انقاذ محليه ودوليه من 90 دوله
استنفذت كل ادواتها ولكل
معداته التقنيه والتقليديه المجربه
والخاضعه للاختبار الفئران المدربه على
كشف الالغام في افريقيا حضرت من بلجك على
الرقعه التركيه المنكوبه بحقيبه ظهر
وكاميرات لترصد من شقوق الركام وفسحاته
الضيقه صوتا او حركه المرجوه
345 الف شقه سكنيه استنسخ قدر ساكنيها
ولربما كان مصيرهم الحياه لو كانت هذه
الصوره الطبقيه الافتراضيه توفرت واقعيا
لمجدتهم غير ان الصور من باطن الارض الى
علوم السماء لا تنقذوا ارواحا سبقها سيف
الوقت
اعطاء الاغاثه والاستجابه المتاخره فمن ظن
في ظلمه الركام انه وحيد
اخطا الصوره تزداد قتامه من ارتفاع تحليق
المسيرات او هكذا يراد منها برصدها حجم
الضرر الذي حل باكثر من 26 مليون شخص خمسه
عشر مليون في تركيا واحد عشر مليون متضرر
تفصلهم الحدود الجنوبيه على الجانب الاخر
البؤس لن يكون مؤقتا والواقع لا يغيره
تاريخ ولا مفاجات او كوارث طبيعيه ان كانت
اصلاحيه فزرجيك البستان وانطاكيا في تركيا
الاكثر تاثرا فعنوان مقاس الكارثه بوقعها
الاعنف تجلى في جنديرس عفرين سلقين حارم
وجبله السوريه
النجوم منهم مصيرهم العراء الدائم غالبا
او المغلف بخيام تاخرت لن ينسى منهم من
تبقت لديه رفاهيه الذكرى ان اولى قوافل
النجده الشحيحه المنقوصه دخلت مناطقهم بعد
اليوم الخامس من وقوع الكارثه يعيش خمسه
ملايين ونصف المليون السوري مع خذلانا قتل
كذلك عددا يبقى غير
ما نعلمه ان نحو سبعه الاف شخص اقضى تحت
انقاض مباني تهدكت بفعل القصف
وتوقف البحث عن المزيد لنقص المعدات
والارض هنا بما يفوق الحصيله غير مؤكده
للضحايا
احتضنت المزيد
اعادتهم كارثه الزلزال من رحله لجوهم الى
تركيا
جثثا هامده
بين السياسي والانساني كثير من المفارقات
وانتشابها مسرحات دمار وتوحدت صيحه الالم
ان كانت تحديات تركيا مربونه بالوقت في
الاسعاف والانقاذ وانتشار الجثث ومن ثم
اعاده الاعمار بتكلفه تقدر بمئه مليار
دولار
فاقارب الساعه
لملايين السوريين احياء وامواتا في عهده
الزلزال توقفت عند الرابعه سبعه عشره
دقيقه فجر السادس من فبراير
[موسيقى]